good work liberals your constant climate
hysteria is now terrorizing an entire
generation of children instead of being
concerned with the boogeyman or monsters
under the bed a top Democrats and global
warming is starting to worry her kids
they've also given us a model to become
our own leaders and let me tell you what
it means to to me coming in as a
different generation I remember my
middle child waking up with nightmares
over concern around climate change these
are the type of experiences that we are
going to bring as we continue to push to
meet the this moment of challenge for
the American people with progress but it
is no wonder the children are scared
climate guilt is all the rage now in the
media a Washington Post analysis piece
telling the story of one mother who
quote couldn't shake the feeling that by
giving birth she might be doing
something bad for the Earth
all right so your child wakes up from a
nightmare about
climate change wouldn't you agree that
fears about climate change are probably
something that a parent instilled in a
child Greg yeah the uh uh a wise man
coined a phrase called narrative
poisoning and this is apocalyptic
poisoning she's poisoned the child's
brain uh that it's imagine instead of
when your kid's crying saying oh
actually there is a monster hiding under
your bed good night because that's
exactly what this is you know there is a
monster's going to come and kill you in
10 years and a kid can't process this
but we're now assuming that kids can
just take on anything like they can
understand
apocalyptic uh predictions or gender
affirmation like kids can understand
their own sexuality at six we are like
we it's all because we've allowed
political ideology to poison which is
essentially a parent-child relationship
hell if you I mean if you agree with Mom
I mean murderers they're environmental
Heroes because for every victim yeah
they pull two carbon Footprints off the
planet good for them them Putin invades
Ukraine 200 000 dead he should be like
he should win the Nobel Prize not Nobel
Prize Nobel Prize all right Jessica
you're big Chloe Cleo is a year old and
are you weighted down by the idea that
your child is simply adding to the
devastation climate change that will
create and the carbon arithmetic on the
cost of her birth I wrote that earlier I
don't know what it means
are you devastated and worried that that
Cleo is now creating a climate disaster
I'm waiting for her second birthday to
start talking to her about the
implications of her footprint the diaper
footprint is crazy though how much waste
those things create but um what should
we do
those cloth ones are disgusting I'm not
doing that what about detergent isn't
detergent a pollutant so you're constant
like you're you're you're like you can't
watch it like it's supposed like what's
the what's better disposable or
non-disposable I don't know I have to
ask yeah the mother
she has a dad too maybe he knows
something
um okay no but there was something else
in um what representative Clark said
that I thought was interesting because
she said she was talking about the
climate stuff and then she also said
when we go to a movie Sometimes they
feel like there's someone in the movie
theater with a gun and that that stuff
is real that kids because they do these
active shooter drills and they're
overwhelmed by the gun violence that's
something that I so wish that our kids
knew nothing about and we need to do
better as a society that they are
exposed to that all right Dana are you
going Greener this season are you giving
Greener gifts like are you throwing over
here I'm going Greener I'm not getting a
tree
so many trees everywhere I don't need to
have one in my apartment as well that's
how I feel about that
um I also I agree on the on the school
shooting thing I do and I I hear that
but I remember it's and it's not just
the parents when they go to when kids go
to school that's when they get all of
this climate change stuff as well I
remember a few years ago a friend of
mine told me that their kid was very
upset going to bed reading a bedtime
story to them because as their bed frame
was made of wood and in school that day
they had learned that America is cutting
down all of its forests and we're going
to ruin the planet because we're cutting
down wood and she didn't want to have a
bed like that anymore so it's coming
from them lots of different angles but
this is what I'm worried about are these
kids going to grow up and be the ones
that are trying to throw tomato juice on
a van Gogh right is that where is that
where this leads we have to have
perspective and it's if the schools are
going to be a problem and the parents
are going to be the problem then I guess
every child in America is going to have
to watch the five okay all right Jesse
there's something called Echo anxiety
and according to the Lancet 59 of kids
between the ages of 16 and 25 are
seriously concerned about the effects of
climate change makes sense Jesse Jr
ripped off his bib this morning and said
dad I couldn't sleep last night knowing
that Joe Biden has a security clearance
I said I understand he said no you don't
his family is under investigation for
foreign money laundering how is it that
the president has access to our most
sensitive Secrets I said son I get it
and then I gave him some Robitussin
now am I allowed to criticize This
Woman's parenting yes go right ahead
because some would say that she's a bad
parent because you're supposed to raise
resilient children you're not supposed
to raise children that run out of a
movie theater or cry about the weather
next Century so I'm going to do
something as Julie don't I'm going to
volunteer to help out here
I'm going to offer to take this
congresswoman's child under my wing and
Mentor this child I will perhaps do
active shooter duty at a Cineplex so
they have the confidence next film or
maybe tell them about climate gate
remember how they fudge the numbers to
make the temperatures look they were
going in that direction I'm willing to
do that and I also did a deep dive on
this woman I couldn't help it did a deep
dive she grew up in New Haven parents
obviously librarian father Nixon voter
Republican attorney typical New Haven
situation and then the parents and the
whole family went into this very strange
Direction I only did this because This
Woman's the next Pelosi without the
charm she's a real high Riser you're
going to be seeing a lot of her
yeah no she's a whip am I allowed to say
whip she's a whip yeah I went on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now